now to the war in ukraine where russia
is reported to be gaining more ground in
the east of the country as the fighting
continues european countries are adding
new economic sanctions against russia
charlie dagon is in london he's got more
on this story charlie good morning to
you good morning to you gail after
months of wrangling finally a
breakthrough overnight the european
union aims to block more than two-thirds
of russian oil imports the council chief
said the deal cuts off a huge source of
financing for russia's war machine and
it is huge
the eu the eu currently pays russia
roughly 430 billion dollars a year for
imports hungary was the only holdout
saying its economy just couldn't cope
without russian oil it is one of the
harshest economic weapons unleashed on
the kremlin since the war began
now in terms of battlefield weapons
president biden said the us would not
supply ukraine with those long-range
weapons that can reach into russia
moscow's threatened to retaliate if
those missiles are used against its
territory but ukrainian commanders on
the ground put it simply to us the
russian military can reach us but we
can't reach them
tony
charlie thank you very much